i'm in central louisiana time to film
louisiana black bears
emerging from their dens
these bears
dim in cypress trees over water in these
very thick
and dangerous sloths
biologists don't know
how the bear actually gets the cubs
from the tree to dry ground
if i can capture this on film this will
be the first time ever
i didn't even see the mother bear for
the first two weeks
and then one day
i look up and her head is sticking out
the hole and i was like
holy cow
this suit has a lot of logistical
challenges
every morning i'm having to wade
right past the entrance hole to the skin
where this mother
there is
waiting with her
so i have to be extremely careful not to
make any noise even the ripples in the
water the sound and splashing my feet
the water those kind of things can i
learn that bear that i'm present
we're dealing with an animal who is an
apex predator and its sense of smell and
hearing
are
really good
and so
i actually have two blinds
that way
depending on what the wind duration is i
can
have the advantage of being downwind
from the gamble
i'm at day 42 now and still nothing
i'm hoping
that we're close but every day
it's an emotional roller coaster
every time i see her that could be the
moment that could be
being she's getting ready to do what
i've been waiting for to do
[Music]
[Music]
dislikes mama and the
sin
this is really cool to watch
the steamy swamp lands of louisiana
as rich in life as a tropical rainforest
around here you got to be able to move
from land to water and from water to
land
this mother proves herself a true
borderland hero
[Music]